You know, for a long time people said,
"Oh, there's no such thing as an
autoimmune condition."
Not true. Okay. What is an autoimmune
condition? An autoimmune condition is
when the body starts to attack itself in
some way. How does that happen? It
happens because of an unhealthy gut. It
happens because things that are being
digested in your body are being allowed
to leave the gut not adequately broken
down either because you don't have
enough stomach acid, you don't have
enough enzymes, you don't have enough
probiotic which helps to build the
enzymes. Something's happening in your
gut. And now what's leaving your gut is
not the normal small,
excuse me, microscopic
um food particles that should leave your
gut. What's leaving your gut is things
that are larger than normal molecules
that should be leaving your gut. And
this is happening because your gut
lining is weakened.
And instead of being really tight
junctions that only the smallest
particles can get through, those
junctions tend to loosen. Inflammation's
going to cause the loosening. And when
you consider the fact that the gut wall
is only one cell thick, it doesn't take
much to damage that gut wall. And so now
what happens is larger than normal food
molecules will leave the gut and go out
into the circulation. When that happens,
the body reacts and responds. The immune
system reacts and says, "Whoa, this is
nonself. There's something wrong here.
We need to get rid of this. We need to
act on this." And we'll begin to mount
an attack. And that's an autoimmune
attack. Now that attack can can happen
in the joints. That attack can happen
anywhere in the body. And people one of
the most underdiagnosed
issues and problems that we have in this
country is Hashimoto's thyroiditis.
Hashimoto's thyroiditis is literally an
autoimmune condition where those toxins
that left the gut, those larger than
normal food molecules, we now call them
toxins, they left the gut, they went,
they now take up residence in the brain,
they now take up residence in the
thyroid, they now take up residence in
the joints. Well, those that take up
residence in the thyroid can cause
significant issues and problems. And
many people who are diagnosed with
thyroiditis actually have an autoimmune
condition, not just a poorly functioning
thyroid.